[Música]
Turquía eligió al presidente reyeta iber
duant por otros cinco años más en la
segunda vuelta electoral del 28 de mayo
le sacó más de cuatro puntos
porcentuales a su opositor Pues erdoan
obtuvo el
52,1% de los votos mientras que quema
altaro se quedó con el
47,9% según los datos del Consejo
supremo electoral con todas las balotas
ya contadas este puntaje muestra que la
mayoría de los turcos siguen respaldando
al gobierno de van y el presidente
continuará así sus veinte años
consecutivos en el poder esto a pesar de
que el país tiene una de las inflaciones
más altas del mundo y de que su gobierno
fue criticado por la falta de gestión
oportuna luego de los terremotos de
febrero de este año que solamente en el
país dejaron 48.000 muertos veamos un
informe sobre las reacciones después de
los comicios
[Aplausos]
ante miles de Seguidores eufóricos
celebró su Victoria en el Palacio
presidencial se queda para un tercer
mandato
[Música]
nuestra nación nos ha confiado de nuevo
esta misión por un periodo de 5 años
debemos centrarnos en nuestros sueños
como nación en nuestras ambiciones y
unirnos
fue también desde ankara que su
contrincante quema el tomó la palabra
para emitir su derrota
el pueblo expresó su voluntad de
rechazar una forma de autocracia pero no
fue suficiente lo que me entristece son
las grandes dificultades que tiene
Turquía por delante
estas elecciones ponen fin a semanas de
campaña muy polarizada una parte del
electorado soñaba con el cambio una
población hastiada de la crisis
económica del hundimiento de la lira
turca y la concentración del poder en la
presidencia pero para hacer frente a los
desafíos la mayoría ha elegido otro
camino el de la estabilidad no es solo
el líder de Turquía sino que recepta
Jeep erdoan es un líder mundial nuestro
único líder nuestro único guía surgieron
concentraciones espontáneas en varias
ciudades turcas incluso aquí en
gaciantepec en esta ciudad azotada por
el Terrible terremoto del pasado febrero
la confianza y perduana no ha flaqueado
no solo ganó en gaseanted también lo
hizo en las provincias de hatay y
karamán maras duramente golpeadas por
los terremotos Cómo ganó entonces
revieta y verduán cuáles son los retos
más difíciles que enfrentará su nuevo
gobierno y que cambian la región con su
Victoria para hablar de esto hoy en el
debate nos acompaña desde Madrid Marta
González especialista en geopolítica
periodista y politóloga en nuestros
estudios en Bogotá nos acompaña Carlos
Manuel Jiménez él es profesor del
departamento de negociación y comercio
internacional de la Universidad de la
sabana y desde Ciudad de México se
conecta Eduardo Salgado licenciado en
relaciones internacionales y quien ha
realizado investigaciones sobre la
historia política de Turquía a todos
ellos bienvenidos y a ustedes nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
hacen parte de este debate pueden dejar
sus comentarios y sus preguntas en todas
las redes sociales donde no se
encuentran como arroba Franz 24 raya al
piso es pueden comentar con la etiqueta
numeral el debate f24 y a mí me
encuentran en Twitter como arroba
maríacle Aguirre no olviden también que
los contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
comenzamos entonces la discusión del día
de hoy para ello quiero darle la
bienvenida a Marta González Marta
Gracias por acompañarnos y empecemos por
responder la pregunta cómo logra ganar
a pesar de la crisis económica y a pesar
de la crisis que Se generó luego de los
terremotos
Hola buenas tardes buenas noches para
España y un placer y un gusto estar otra
vez con ustedes pues se explica por
varios motivos en primer lugar porque la
sociedad turca está muy polarizada como
lo habéis explicado en el reportaje y
porque la población ha apostado al final
por la continuidad de un dirigente que a
pesar de lo controvertido que resulta en
occidente y también para una parte
importante de la población turca ha
llegado Ha logrado grandes avances de
modernización del país y sobre todo Lia
catapultado a uno de los principales
puestos como como potencia regional con
con influencia internacional en los
resultados se pueden explicar de varias
maneras por un lado porque hay una
profunda
influencia de las políticas identitarias
y en la sociedad turca que ha calado y
sobre todo ha calado en esta en esta
campaña electoral en la que se han
enfrentado dos modos de entender el país
por un lado el nacionalismo arraigándolo
también con el con el la identidad
musulmana y por otro lado las ansias de
libertad y de democracia y de
distanciamiento
económico que no han cuajado al final
por otro lado hemos visto también una
campaña muy polarizada una oposición que
ha estado muy dividida que no ha tenido
techo electoral fue fuerte y eso ha sido
un hándicap también que ha utilizado a
su favor erdogan que después de veinte
años en el poder utiliza y dispone de
todos los resortes de comunicación a su
favor por otro lado
no continúe terminé la idea tranquila
termino y por otro lado Tenemos también
una política exterior que ha sido muy
agresiva pero que ha dado réditos a
nivel de nacionalismo interno por lo
tanto
esos factores de alguna manera
consolidan la el regreso o mejor dicho
la continuidad de erdogan en unas
políticas que no van a no van a cambiar
significativamente ni en el ni en el
campo interno ni en la política exterior
creo que usted apunta a todos los
elementos que queremos discutir hoy en
el debate tanto internamente como en las
políticas exteriores que manejará erdoan
pero le quiero preguntar a usted Carlos
Manuel Jiménez y gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros cómo es posible que afuera
de Turquía por ejemplo en la Unión
Europea cada vez se diga que erdoan es
cada vez más autócrata pero dentro de
Turquía se el poder luego de 20 años
como lo ven los turcos y Cuál es la
diferencia frente a la imagen
internacional que se tiene del
presidente creo que Hay momentos en la
historia donde
hay que acudir a conceptos como el de la
nación de las fuerzas históricas de la
Providencia o de las mismas fuerzas
civilizacionales de una gran nación como
la turca para poder entender lo que hoy
estamos viviendo
es insólito para los medios occidentales
tratar de entender lo que el triunfo en
un país de alguna manera que ha venido
teniendo una caída muy significativa en
su moneda que vivió un golpe de estado
que padeció un terremoto que le ha
costado casi 9% del pib y que toda la
prensa internacional de alguna manera lo
ha tildado de autócrata y ha cuestionado
realmente los fundamentos de su
civilización
y es en ese contexto donde yo creo que
es importante acudir al concepto de la
de la nación no del pueblo el pueblo de
alguna manera es un concepto
racional de la modernidad donde depriman
las mayorías un conjunto de egos que
toman decisiones y se pueden perder por
uno dos tres cuatro por ciento creo que
Hay momentos en la historia donde estas
fenómenos los explica es la nación y son
eso las fuerzas de la historia y creo
que esto no es un caso aislado de alguna
manera occidente se está viendo
absolutamente resquebrajado frente a
países que están imponiendo un relato
Imperial y civilizacional que está
cuestionando los valores la axiología
las ideologías y los relatos de
occidente de alguna manera y eso le
cuesta trabajo entender a los medios
occidentales pero erdogan se está
configurando como un Sultán
de alguna manera son de los antiguos
mitos y visiones civilizacionales de un
mundo cesaro papista donde lo religioso
y lo y lo se fusionan son sociedades
jerárquicas imperiales creo que esa es
la única manera de entender hoy a Moscú
sí como un zar o incluso la misma china
que está tratando también de buscar su
pasado Imperial y es en ese contexto
donde donde
es la mejor manera de entender realmente
algo que que para occidente
era bastante insólito y todas las
grandes potencias occidentales hicieron
todo lo posible porque un Aliado de
occidente Y de Washington llegarán cara
y no se logró y no se logró precisamente
por un concepto que usted habla y es la
nación sobre esto Le quiero preguntar a
Eduardo Salgado porque el tercer
candidato de la primera vuelta que era
sinaloan es del partido del movimiento
nacionalista del mhp y él Aunque obtuvo
muy pocos votos en la primera vuelta de
hace dos semanas quedó con el 5,2% de
los sufragios
el respaldo abiertamente a erdoan que
tanto peso tienen los nacionalismos y
las ideas nacionalistas en esta segunda
vuelta que le permitió la victoria a
Eduard
Hola Qué tal Buenas tardes primero que
muchas gracias por la invitación Es un
honor para mí estar acá yo Esa es la
respuesta la pregunta más complicada
quizás en en el espectro político Turco
porque hay varios tipos de nacionalismo
que analizar en en una sociedad como la
de Turquía no nacionalismo que quizás
está relacionado con algunas
concepciones europeas que tienen que ver
con supremacismo étnicos con el rechazo
al al flujo migratorio
algo quizás relacionado también con con
religión no la mayoría sunita en Turquía
pero
lo siento que lo que pasa o lo que puede
pasar en este momento es que hay una
combinación de todo eso en diferentes
nacionalismos
en Turquía no sé cuál podría decirlo en
este momento que que la principal fuente
del nacionalismo es un es un rechazo a
políticas antioccidentales quizás o a
una visión antioccidental que ha tratado
de
reducir a las sociedades que no que no
pertenecen históricamente no a ellos y
una de ellas es la turca especialmente
por la cuestión islámica y toda la y
todo el discurso que se ha hecho del
islam a partir de de en el último
Milenio no Eduardo usted habla usted
habla de varios nacionalismos en este
sentido Quiero preguntarle cuál es el
peso del islam porque el akp es el
partido
de erdogan inicialmente hace unos 20
años comenzó como una opción para ser
una alternativa al ala más radical del
islamismo y poco a poco erdogan pasó de
proteger el laicismo en Turquía a
defender más abiertamente el islamismo y
las posturas de los musulmanes en ese
qué tanto peso tuvo esto en los comicios
yo creo que mucho mucho especialmente
por La retórica que hubo de erdogan en
contra de de quilice no y su y su la
vertiente religiosa a Levi en Turquía no
ahí hay mucha hay un se me hace que lo
podría comparar con el mito fundacional
que del que estaba hablando del que
estábamos hablando hace unos segundos
hace unos momentos y decir que en
realidad la fuerza política religiosa de
de Turquía está basada en el en el en el
islam sunita Entonces sí hay sí hay una
retórica en contra de la de las minorías
religiosas que que conviven en en en en
en en en Turquía Pero también es el ser
abanderado de la religión se paran ha
servido mucho en su en su desempeño
político no se decía sí lo lo veo veo un
peso fuerte especialmente también con
los kurdos no hay una hay un discurso
muy fuerte de erdogan en contra de
kirlich que tiene que ver con los kurdos
no el apoyo de kurdos El apoyos de
terroristas que podría significar el
apoyo de los kurdos y también por por la
por pertenecer a una
versión heterodoxa de del islam no que
es la galería Marta Quiero hablar con
usted un punto que está tratando de
Eduardo y es uno eduardán como uno de
los líderes visibles del islam sunita
pero le quiero preguntar a usted si esto
genera divisiones y políticas
opuestas en Turquía si esto está
generando más divisiones adentro y dos
precisamente con los con Los kurdos Cuál
es el panorama Porque ahora el
presidente en su discurso de Victoria lo
que dijo Es el colíder de un partido
kurdo permanecerá en la cárcel donde
está desde 2016
si efectivamente como ha dicho el
anterior ponter Tulio Yo creo que el
islam es un o la versión sunita del
islam la versión que el propio erdogan
tiene del islam es fundamental a la hora
de entender no solamente es el islam
como religión personal sino también la
concepción del Estado trasladada también
a los nacionalismos que hay en Turquía
yo creo que hay una
una relación ambigua respecto de los
kurdos el los kurdos no son un pueblo
unitario y unívoco tampoco son
homogéneos por lo tanto hay diferentes
tipos hay diferentes partidos y
diferentes sensibilidades de hecho uno
de los partidos kurdos que ha sido muy
cuestionado por erdogan durante la
campaña que ha apoyado a la campaña a la
campaña opositora precisamente por su
laicismo está cerrado y porque en la del
islam que tiene erdogan eran
antipatriotas y estaban en contra de los
valores de la nación islámica por otro
lado no hay que olvidar que en estos 20
años de gobierno de erdogan ha tenido
una posición muy favorable con la parte
curda que es no es nacionalista
separatista sino que tiene una identidad
acorde con la identidad
nacional turca y también ha hecho
cambios muy significativos a la hora de
establecer una identidad
separada de los kurdos pero
coincidiendo también con la nación que
pudiera ser integrada en la nacionalidad
turca sin sin problemas no Entonces yo
yo creo que en este momento no va a
haber más
disputas o más problemas con los kurdos
de los que ha habido ahora Simplemente
hay una continuidad en la narrativa Es
verdad que el gobierno va a estar
formado por una coalición de partidos
que son un poco más extremistas que el
propio partido de erdogan o la visión
que tienen respecto del nacionalismo es
mucho más agresiva pero la figura de
erdogan tiene peso propio y yo creo que
con el tiempo va a conseguir neutralizar
las voces discordantes y no va a haber
ningún problema a la hora de gestionar
las relaciones con las minorías como lo
está haciendo hasta ahora romanuel usted
estaba de acuerdo con este punto en que
a pesar de que en el parlamento de la
Cape va a ser alianzas con partidos
todavía más extremistas esto herbal lo
logrará controlar o tendremos Un
gobierno como se estima desde Bruselas
que cada vez se irá más a los extremos y
será más autócrata yo creo que al igual
que los otros contertulios
y la anterior
profesora que acaba de intervenir
Considero que estos liderazgos fuertes
inspiradores de alguna manera que han
logrado movilizar hitos símbolos
religiosos que se convierten en
referentes de la nación de alguna manera
logran modelar y generar acuerdos
colectivos y logran ser liderazgos
transformadores que terminan
beneficiando a todo a todo el país en
momentos supremamente difíciles tanto a
nivel monetario económico geopolítico y
en ese sentido un gobierno autoritario
no significa per se una tiranía genocida
como se puede llegar a catalogar de
manera simplista sino que son liderazgos
fuertes liderazgos inspiradores y que
logran transformar a toda una nación
negociar con sus minorías y acuerdos
colectivos para el bien común de la
nación Aquí tengo dos preguntas Cómo
entender la figura de este liderazgo
fuerte en los países más cercanos al
mundo árabe como Turquía y demás
mientras que desde el mundo occidental
esto se ve como una autocracia pero cómo
entender desde adentro desde Turquía en
este caso el liderazgo de estas figuras
que permanecen décadas ya erdoan lleva
dos décadas en el poder y dos como
contraponer esto frente Por ejemplo al
aumento de las detenciones de los
opositores y de los periodistas que se
ha incrementado en Turquía desde el
intento del golpe de estado en 2016
en ese sentido creo que la tradición
democrática de estos países pues es
bastante
superficial no se puede comparar Sí con
sociedades constitucionales o con
ciudadanos de alguna manera
homogeneizados por la economía
completamente alejados de la religión
estamos hablando de una sociedad
profundamente tradicional de ahí que
estos liderazgos autoritarios son
liderazgos tradicionales y estos
liderazgos tradicionales tienen un
arraigambre muy marcada con el pasado
con la religión con las jerarquías con
unas visiones imperiales de alguna
manera aquí hay que recordar que aquí
hay todo un relato y una visión Imperial
de un país que ha cumplido durante
milenios un lugar supremamente
importante para conectar la
civilizaciones y que de alguna manera
hoy lo están lo está haciendo en un
escenario geopolítico también bastante
transformador desafiante
eh donde Los criterios
democráticos o de decisiones
completamente democráticas siempre
signadas por la por las mayorías
parlamentarias Pues de alguna manera
experimentan un desfase frente a
ejecutivos y liderazgos claramente
fuertes que son
interpretados en occidente como
autoritarios el talante
hemos visto sobre todo en la economía
porque él se ha mantenido en su postura
de tener las tasas de interés a la baja
con la idea de que esto ayudará a
reducir la inflación en estos momentos
la inflación turca está cerca del 50%
que es una de las más altas del mundo y
erdoan en su discurso de Victoria
prometió que la tasa de interés fijada
por el Banco Central permanecería en
ocho coma cinco por ciento esto para
tener una comparación hace dos años era
del
19%. sin embargo varios economistas
dicen y están en contra de la idea de
que mantener las tasas de interés a la
baja ayudará a reducir la inflación y la
economía es el principal reto que tiene
erdogan en medio de la crisis que
enfrenta el país y el mismo lo reconoció
que sería la tarea principal en este
sentido Eduardo Le quiero preguntar qué
tanto margen de maniobra tiene erdoan
respecto a la economía a la depreciación
de la lira y al aumento de la inflación
creo que en estos momentos hay varias
hay varios signos de
en las relaciones internacionales de
Turquía que podrían coadyuvar en en
el saneamiento económico de interno de
Turquía y eso creo que lo va a explotar
mucho este año por ejemplo que
encontraron las en las
reservas de petróleo en el sur de en el
sur de de Turquía también habla y le da
la le da esta le permite Hablar a
erdogan de que Turquía puede convertirse
también en un exportador de petróleo en
los próximos años
él le da también ahí una una fuerza a su
discurso de que las cosas pueden cambiar
también según de acuerdo con datos por
ejemplo de los indicadores de gobernanza
sustentable Turquía es uno de los países
que más
no es que de dinero sino que es parte de
programas de desarrollo a nivel regional
beneficiando muchas veces a pasomalia
Palestina Afganistán Bosnia kirguistán
eso también le da una imagen con con
algunos otros
quizás no competidores pero con otros
estados otros actores de la región que
también pueden darle un sustento mayor a
la economía
turca por ejemplo y especialmente creo
eh con los los países del Golfo no las
las monarquías del Golfo y también que
está tratando de hacer un una
aproximación en esta idea que ha tenido
o que ha desarrollado erdogan del del
Blue homeland no del de la patria azul
tratar de reconquistar algunos espacios
en el Mediterráneo para la exploración
de petróleo para el tránsito de
de mercancías no de las cadenas de
suministro esto también lo va a ayudar a
acercarse a países por ejemplo como
Egipto en este momento y también podría
va a estar y podría
también respaldarse del del de las
buenas relaciones que va a tener con las
monarquías del Golfo para acercarse a
Egipto y ganar también en ese aspecto
ahora en lo interno Perdón es a mí
también se me hace difícil de entender
no el el la la forma en que está
tratando de pensar la idea de mantener
la tasa de interés baja para ayudar a la
economía en lo interno pero también lo
el sustento y también una de las cosas
que le dio mucha fuerza en lo político
para estas elecciones fue que al mismo
tiempo está inyectando mucho dinero en
programas sociales y en pensiones y en
salarios mínimos no Entonces eso y que
la gente esté aumentando el gasto que
más bien que la gente siga manteniendo
el gasto
nivelado no que el que lo que esté
gastando la gente se vaya entre los
mismos sectores de la sociedad le ha
dado también un un hay un margen de
respalda entre la gente porque ven no
ven que el dinero que está inyectando el
gobierno se vaya a manos de élite sino
que se está manteniendo entre la gente
gastando con las tiendas locales con los
proveedores locales aprovecho aprovecho
que usted en la primera parte de su
pregunta relacionó un poco la situación
económica turca con las relaciones sobre
todo con medio oriente y usted utiliza
una palabra también utilizó acercarse
acercarse al mundo árabe es lo que
prometedoan sobre todo con países como
Egipto Arabia Saudita y emiratos árabes
Unidos con los que no ha tenido tan
buenas relaciones luego de la llamada
Primavera árabe Marta usted cree que
esto se la reelección de erdogan
beneficiará la relación de Turquía y el
mundo árabe
sin duda yo creo que no va a haber
cambios significativos en política
exterior
de todas formas
tradicionalmente Turquía se ha debatido
siempre entre esas dos almas la
euroasiática por un lado y por otro lado
la mediterránea y la de oriente medio
estamos hablando de un país con una
cultura y una tradición con carácter de
potencia hegemónica no es un país árabe
Aunque es un país musulmán de religión
mayoritariamente suni de confesión
mayoritariamente suni pero desde el
punto de vista económico está muy
está muy necesitado no solamente de
acercarse a los países del Golfo por
esas razones económicas de
diversificación de su economía y de
mejora de su economía sino también
porque en Oriente medio desde 2020 se
está viviendo un muy muy significativo
en el ámbito de las relaciones
internacionales que se están abriendo
con Los acuerdos de Abraham y que son
las relaciones de normalización de
Israel con los países del Golfo y con
otros países de la zona y Turquía ha
establecido otra vez relaciones de
confianza con Israel en 2022 y no quiere
salirse de ese tren y no quiere estar al
margen de ese tren por lo tanto yo creo
que Turquía no solamente no va a cambiar
ni a modificar su política exterior sino
que con el tiempo podría incluso
suavizar las tensiones que mantiene con
países o con
minorías que tradicionalmente ha estado
en litigio por ejemplo con las
relaciones con Israel siempre mantiene
una relación es un poco distanciadas
respecto del problema de la cuestión
palestino israelí pero desde el punto de
vista dogmático yo creo que va a ser muy
significativo el acuerdo que mantiene no
solamente con
Qatar sino también con emiratos Árabes y
en el futuro muy próximo con Arabia
saudí vemos entonces de un lado como
Turquía se acerca medio oriente no solo
por razones económicas sino también
geopolíticas con este nuevo cambio de
ajedrez desde 2020 con Los acuerdos de
Abraham como usted nos dice pero Carlos
Manuel cómo Entonces se plantea Turquía
en lo que Marta habla de la segunda alma
La euroasiática Cómo se plantea sus
relaciones con la Unión Europea que cada
vez más a lo largo de sus 20 años de
gobierno se ha apartado creo que es un
país que
está de alguna manera destinado a jugar
un papel fundamental de bisagra de una
manera es miembro de la otan tiene el
segundo ejército más poderoso de la otan
ha jugado un papel muy importante de
alguna manera
una marcada reticencia para involucrar a
Finlandia Suecia dentro del marco de la
otan y ha sido un Aliado estratégico de
Moscú es decir aquí realmente hay que
entender que estamos viviendo un proceso
de desdolarización muy marcado realmente
la dolarización en un país con una
economía tan hiperinternacionalizada
como la turca realmente ha sido una
inflación importada aquí hay que pensar
que en el último año casi que se ha
emitido el 25% de dólares a lo largo de
toda la historia el llamado m2 realmente
la inflación es un problema que lo están
padeciendo ellos por una política
monetaria absolutamente desbocada y
delirante que están manejando los bancos
centrales y claramente la Fed en ese
contexto el mundo está viviendo un
proceso de dolarización muy marcado y
realmente las transacciones en todas
estas nuevas riquezas petroleras que se
que se han encontrado en el bósforo y
todos los acuerdos comerciales por fuera
el sistema del banco Swift que es el
banco occidental donde es absolutamente
necesario recurrir al sistema Euro dólar
Turquía está jugando un papel muy
importante dentro de ese proceso de
dolarización porque realmente lo que
estamos viviendo es un desacople
estructural financiero de las economías
donde el el el el el
la lira van a jugar un papel muy
importante y claramente el yuan y el
rublo y y Arabia Saudita de alguna
manera Está jugando un papel muy
importante porque los precios hoy del
crudo no los está fijando como se
fijaron desde 1973 por una alianza
informal implícita entre Arabia y
Estados Unidos sino que se está
recurriendo otro tipo de variables y
otro tipo de acuerdos donde Estados
Unidos realmente no está definiendo el
precio del crudo y es todas estas
potencias de alguna manera las que van a
entrar a jugar un papel muy importante
que es para controlar una inflación que
en los próximos años es imposible que
vuelva al nivel del 2% y en ese papel es
tan importante que pueden contar estas
estos nuevos países o estas diferentes
potencias como entra a Turquía Eduardo
en su papel de bisagra en términos uno
monetarios con la desdolarización que
vive en el mundo como nos lo está
explicando el profesor Carlos Manuel y
dos por ejemplo en la otan donde el voto
de Turquía fue decisivo para permitir
que Finlandia se uniera al grupo del
Atlántico Norte y también ha sido
decisivo en bloquear la pertenencia de
Suecia en ese sentido en el militar Y en
el económico cómo juega la reelección de
aduana
es buena pregunta
A mí me parece lo más el tema más
interesante que que viene en el futuro
cercano para para erdogan porque siento
que se se ha dejado algunas cartas que
le han que le permiten mantener un
negociaciones de su lado de la mesa con
Europa por ejemplo Suecia no Suecia va a
ser creo en el primer año de erdoan va a
ser
el el tema que le va a permitir estar
negociando a su favor O quizás ganando
algunas algunas negociaciones con Europa
no especialmente porque
que que y esto especialmente hablando de
que no se ve un futuro claro para
terminar la guerra entre Rusia y Ucrania
entonces mientras se mantenga La amenaza
rusa
cerca de las puertas de Europa
occidental y cerca de las puertas de la
otan Turquía va a tener esta carta para
para tener algo a su favor con con ellos
no Entonces
en este primer año Veo veo a la a la
Turquía de erdogan utilizando la carta
de Suecia para ganarse también algunas
algunos favores pero al final va a pasar
si si lo tuviera que predecir creo que
Turquía va a permitir la entrada de
Suecia a la a la otan especialmente
ahora que ya pasaron los la los comicios
electorales
ya ya no tiene por qué dar esta cara de
de enfrentamiento con alguien que con
quien no le conviene no que es la otan
los mismos miembros de la otan y hay
otra carta que que lastimosamente por
temas de tiempo no la podemos abordar y
es el tema de los migrantes que Turquía
y especialmente el presidente erdogan
siempre la ha utilizado como mecanismo
de presión a la Unión Europea
lastimosamente se nos acaba el tiempo
Eduardo Entonces quiero pedirle Cuál es
su conclusión de cómo entender la
reelección de revierta y verdoán en
Turquía muy brevemente
sí lo tenemos que entender desde un
punto de vista en que van veinte años de
gobierno y en estos veinte años de
gobierno a nivel local ha habido muchas
mejoras en las condiciones sociales ha
habido una un avance muy fuerte en en la
posición turca global no a nivel Global
en las cadenas de suministro se planta
como un líder esto a mí me parece muy
importante lo que se apuntó durante
durante el debate que es un líder no en
una en una sociedad acostumbrada a
líderes fuertes que además Está también
dándole un lugar de de supremacía a
Turquía en la región
lo podemos entender también desde el
punto de vista en que el nacionalismo de
erdogan ha separado o no le ha dado
fuerza al al a este discurso occidental
en el que la sociedad turca es menor o
la sociedad musulmana es menor a otras
Entonces eso creo que nos da nos daría
la idea de de por qué tiene tanto
respaldo a nivel local y Por qué mucha
gente del 52% de la gente lo sigue
respaldando Marta Cuál es su conclusión
mi conclusión es muy parecida Turquía
Apuesta por la continuidad una sociedad
que está profundamente dividida en dos
almas en el alma más conservador más
tradicional producto y
y de su propia herencia
Imperial y por otro lado una sociedad
que Apuesta por la democracia por el
laicismo por la apertura y el
progresismo Pero dentro de un marco de
conservadurismo propio de una cultura
tradicional que se enmarca en Oriente
medio porque es un país de oriente medio
con una pata en occidente Y eso es una
parte que todavía los occidentales no
terminamos de entender porque Turquía
forma parte de un entramado
social económico de Naciones donde el
nacionalismo está intrínsecamente ligado
a la religión muy brevemente Carlos
Manuel cuál es su conclusión y veo que
nos un poco de la visión occidental para
entender Más el alma turca en estas
elecciones Yo creo que la misma idea que
señalé al principio creo que estamos en
un momento histórico un punto de
inflexión muy claro y creo que en estos
momentos la nación las fuerzas
civilizacionales la memoria Imperial la
religiosidad
la visión jerárquica de la sociedad y un
orden cósmico del mundo creo que
empiezan a imperar un occidente de
alguna manera completamente ni lista hoy
no lo entiende Pero creo que esto es una
lección histórica y creo que veremos
muchas por venir bueno gracias a Carlos
Manuel Jiménez por acompañarnos y
también a Eduardo Salgado y a Marta
González Gracias también por todas sus
opiniones y estos puntos de vista tan
interesantes así llegamos al final del
debate de la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y
la de los invitados con Tania Herrera
ustedes pueden seguir comentando en
todas nuestras redes sociales y los
invito a que sigan conectados con las 24
[Música]